there is a moment in which the first
mate
Starbuck they have this raving on and
and they have and and the first mate who
represents Christian right reason
tries to inject a note of sanity into
this undertaking in other words he's the
straight man
he stands for Calvinism rectitude reason
science and he says speaking to Ahab
Starbuck says a hub has just shouted to
the crew art not game for Moby Dick and
Starbuck says I am game for his crooked
jaw and for the jaws of death to Captain
Ahab if it fairly comes in the way of
the business we follow but I came here
to hunt whales not my commanders
vengeance how many barrels will die
vengeance heal thee even if thou gavest
it captain they have it will not fetch
thee much in our Nantucket market
Nantucket market hoot but look closer
man now require us the little lower
layer if money is to be the measure man
and the accountants have computed their
great Counting house the globe by
girdling it with guineas one two every
three parts of an inch then let me tell
thee that my vengeance will fetch a
great premium here he smites his chest
whispered Stubb what's that for
methinks it rings most vast but hollow
and then Starbuck delivers the
vengeance on a dumb brute cried starbuck
that simply smoked Lee from blindest
instinct madness to be enraged with a
dumb thing captain they have scenes
blasphemous and they have says hark ye
yet again a little lower layer all
visible objects fan are but as
pasteboard masks but in each event in
the living act the undoubted deed there
are some unknown but still reasoning
thing puts forth the moldings of
features from beneath the unreasoning
mask if man will strike strike through
the mask how can the prisoner reach
outside except by thrusting through the
wall to me the white whale is that wall
shoved near to me sometimes I think
there's not beyond but tis enough he
tasks me he heats me I see in him
outrageous strength with an inscrutable
malice signalling it that inscrutable
thing is chiefly what I hate and be the
white whale agent or be the white whale
principle I will wreck that hate upon
him talk not to me of blasphemy man I'd
strike out the Sun if it insulted me or
could the Sun do that then could I do
the other since there is ever a sort of
fair play here in jealousy presiding
over all creations but not my master man
is even that Fair Play who's over me
truth have no confines take off thine
eye more intolerable than fiends glaring
Zizza doltish stare so so now redness
and palest my heart has melted thee to
anger glow but looking star
what is said in eat that thing unsafe
itself there are men from whom warm
words are small and dignity I meant not
to insensitive let it go let it go look
young Turkish cheeks have spotted Tom
living breathing pictures painted by the
Sun the pagan leopards the unrecognized
and seek and give no reasons for the
torrid lights they feel the cruel man
the crew are they not one and all what
they have in this matter of the whale
see Stubb he laughs see yonder Chilean
he snorts to think of it stand up amid
the general hurricane by one toss
sapling cannot Starbuck and what is it
reckon it it is the to help strike a fin
no wondrous speed for Starbuck what is
it more from this one for hunt then the
best Lance out of all Nantucket surely
he will not hang back when every for
mast hand has clutched a whetstone or
constraining sees the I see the billow
lifts thee speak but speak i vice
silence then that voices thee and then
in inside something shot from my dilated
nostrils he has inhaled it in his long
starbuck now is mine cannot oppose me
now without rebellion